on ne connaît un peu plus sur le plan du
gouvernement le go pour l'implantation
de nouvelles classes de maternelle 4 ans
au québec faut dire que c'est vraiment
un des projets phares de la cac alors y
aura 250 classes de plus dès l'année
scolaire 2019 2020 alors ça va porter le
nombre de classes total à 644 dans la
province et pour en parler je reçois le
ministre de l'éducation jean françois
roberge
alors dites nous monsieur roberge qu'on
sait qu'il ya plusieurs écoles qui
déborde ans notamment dans la région de
montréal comment vous allez faire pour
ajouter ces classes là d'abord c'est
classe
on les a choisis en concertation avec
les commissions scolaires je leur avais
envoyé un sondage en décembre dernier
savoir dans quelle mesure il y avait des
classes de disponibles et des
enseignants aussi pour pour accueillir
ces élèves là si nous avait dit on en a
deux là pour seulement 100 classe on
n'aurait pas déborder cette cette limite
là et finalement un peu plus de 250
places étaient disponibles en avait en
vérifiant pourrait bien certains on est
sûr sûr sûr d'avoir de la place dans des
classes des enseignants des
professionnels pour ajouter 250 places
on est très content a donc on lance le
déploiement sur cinq a modestement de
150 places ça peut sembler beaucoup mais
en même temps on ne peut plus d'ambition
que ça pour nos jeunes en cas on veut
que les pareil choix ultime meganck 250
places qui seront vraiment disponible
sans problème sur la place disponible à
partir de la prochaine rentrée scolaire
ans et plus de plus c'est quand on
augmente le nombre de classes de
primates avec quatre ans de plus de 50%
donc c'est quand même
proportionnellement une belle
augmentation on est très fiers on a vu
que le nombre de classes l'ajustement
varie d'une commission scolaire à
londres sur quels critères donc vous
êtes basé vous l'avais un peu expliqué
pour le pour distribuer ses classes
lancé par concertation avec les
commissions scolaires c'est ça en
discussion avec les partenaires avec les
commissions scolaires on s'est entendu
pour un redéploiement qui respecte la
capacité d'accueil éventuellement il y
en aura davantage parce qu'on va en
bâtir des écoles on va m'agrandir des
écoles mais à ce moment si on avait le
souci d'en ajouter dans toutes les
régions du québec mais surtout surtout
le souci de le faire dans le respect du
milieu puis de s'assurer que des places
puis des places de qualité pour ça
vous présentez aussi aujourd'hui le fait
qu'il doit avoir au moins six élèves de
milieux défavorisés par classe comment
est ce que vous allez déterminer
justement que ces élèves là proviennent
d'un milieu défavorisé se baser sur le
revenu des parents comment vous allez
évaluer ça les indices de milieux
défavorisés à sion sont utilisés en
éducation depuis de nombreuses années
pour ajouter des ressources
particulières au delà de ce qu'on donne
à tous les élèves donc certaines écoles
sont classés en milieu défavorisé selon
deux critères essentiellement laisser
leurs revenus des parents
le niveau de scolarité de la marque sont
deux indicateurs des prix indicatifs la
des taux de réussite donc on investit là
où ça peut compter le plus cette année
on est obligé de tenir compte de ça et
on le fait c'est une bonne chose d'une
certaine manière mais à compter de
l'année d'après 2020 on va pouvoir faire
du déploiement sans nécessairement tenir
compte de son mât voir offrir le libre
choix de plus en plus aux parents peu
importe son 1000 défavorisés ou pas
parce qu'on va modifier la loi en ce
sens là et le personnel enseignant
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure mais
puisque vous allez le prendre
écoutez c'est vrai que dans certains
endroits presque des pénuries enfin des
raretés de personnel mais c'est pas vrai
à la grandeur du québec
c'est vrai que des fois on peine à
trouver des suppléants mais c'est pas
vrai à la grandeur du québec ces pauvres
dans toutes les commissions scolaires
les commissions scolaires nous ont dit
qu'ils avaient aucun problème pour
accueillir au moins 250 places de plus
de plus de prématernelle 4
quand on regarde le nombre d'écoles ya
plus est presque 3000 écoles au québec
dont 250 places c'est pas la mer à boire
d'ailleurs on va valoriser la profession
enseignante notre gouvernement on y
tient on va implanter des programmes
d'insertion professionnelle de mentorat
pour garder nos enseignants qui font le
choix cette profession là pour pas
qu'ils abandonnent dans les premières
années on va réinvestir dans des
services directs aux élèves pour aider
les profs à aider les élèves monaco on a
confiance nous de ramener des gens qui
ont peut-être quitter la profession les
dernières années parce qu'ils vont voir
qu'il ya un gouvernement qui priorise
l'éducation on a de la difficulté à
comprendre qu'est ce qui va se passer
avec les enseignantes
versus les éducatrices qu'est ce qu'ils
voient comment ça va s'articuler là dans
la journée de ses enfants dès la
maternelle 4 ans est ce que les
éducatrices vous aller les prendre du
réseau des cpe pour les transférer vers
ces maternelle là comment ça va se faire
c'est bien que vous vous parliez de
cette façon là on fait pas le
déploiement de la prématernelle 4-1
contre le réseau des services de garde
ou ou contre les cpe d'ailleurs on va
continuer de déployer d'agrandir de
construire de nouveaux cpu il on prévoit
qu'il y aura pas mal d'enfants qui vont
s'ajouter dans les 0 3 1 04 à 1 petit
baby-boom donc il ya de la place
il ya de la place pour tout le monde
ensuite bu durant le temps tu places il
y aura un enseignant bien souvent une
enseignante assisté d'une éducatrice une
technicienne spécialisé donc vraiment un
service de qualité en plus des
professionnels et si les parents vont
conduire les enfants plus tôt à l'école
avant qu'elle ne commence
ce qu'on appelle du pigment la journée
de classe b hier services de garde qui
ont mis en a dans toutes les écoles
primaires du québec comme on le fait
pour les enfants de la maternelle 5 en
ce moment monsieur robert j avais ce
front commun vous l'avez vu l'un peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui des services des
intervenantes en petite enfance
également vos collègues de l'opposition
qui disent écoutez le réseau de cpr
répond déjà aux besoins de ses enfants
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez deux
choses d'abord faut faire attention là
ya à peu près 75 % des enfants de 4 ans
qui ne sont pas en cpe avait bien
entendu 75 % des enfants de 4 ans ne
sont pas dans un cpe dont il ya de la
place en mars comme on dit pour déployer
le réseau des maternelles sans même
qu'un seul enfin le transfert des cpe
aux maternelles ensuite faut faire
attention avec la notion de front commun
oui les oppositions étaient leurs
aujourd'hui elles se sont opposés à être
vraiment surprenant non dans la jeu
logique de politique partisane les
oppositions se repose un peu triste mais
c'est ça on pourrait dire qu'un front
commun en faveur de la maternelle ou si
il ya le parti qui est au gouvernement
qui est en faveur
la doyenne de la faculté des dandys
séances d'éducation de l'uqam
le professeur émérite égide royer la
fédération des comités de parents des
comités de parents qui sont en faveur du
déploiement l'ordre des psychologues
dont vous voyez faut faire attention
front commun dans l'impression que tout
le monde est conçu alors que c'est
elle m'en fous là merci beaucoup
monsieur roberge afin que les mrc